salut aujourd'hui une vidéo dans la
catégorie mentale fun on va faire un
escape game en vidéo on l'a déjà fait
une fois avec l'oit vous pouvez cliquer
ici pour le voir on fait l'épisode 2 qui
j'imagine ce sera un petit peu plus dur
la première fois on a alterné loïc et
moi dans les skype pour essayer de se
chauffer là on va faire le même escape
en même temps on verra déjà si l'un des
deux s'en sort et si les 200 sortes
lequel était plus rapide que l'autre
attention c'est parti à trop de blabla
ah si il ya ça et maintenant le point
tournée de spectacles de fabien olicard
vous pouvez passer cette séquence avec
ce time conne mais après faut pas me
demander quand est-ce que je passe chez
vous parce que j'ai déjà fait 30 villes
depuis le mois de septembre je serai un
spectacle à saint-etienne le 26 février
mais c'est complet le 10 mars à besançon
le 16 mars à vias le 22 mars à arles le
23 mars à palavas le 29 mars à
saint-astier mais c'est complet
également le 30 mars à joué-lès-tours et
pis toute manière il ya plein de ville
une trentaine genre lyon toulouse mais
aussi quatre dates exceptionnelles à
paris du 25 au 28 avril au cabba c'est
parti à femme est un cas des trous là où
le téléphone téléphone
voilà je m'appelle je dis maintenant
allô allô cette journée tu as vu on va
avoir deux minutes trente
allez j'ai un contrôle fiscal c'est
parti déclare et les placements de
produits alors
à alors c'est quoi ce choix de salades
pour détruire les trucs mais je dirais
la même chose ce n'est pas bien un
soutien sur le mode saas c'était paris
alors là ils soudent caisse et je suis
cool of war ok ya un code sur l'a51
jusqu'au col largement des deux là
l'argument alors allons voir assez ça
j'ai trouvé le truc pour détruire les
papiers je te dirai jamais où ça fait
qu'est-ce qu'on peut au sein de la
maison voilà c'est vraiment très bizarre
comment ils se déplacent remercié les
uns en fait j'ai pas du tout envie de
dire ce que je trouve pas ce que loïc
mouny m'écoute
non ça parlera de gameplay est toujours
aussi passionnant d'amis ça se passe
quand on éteint la lumière
non mais si j'ai vu toi t'as pas vu nos
six mois j'ai bien bien vu mon gars
temps j'observe qu'est-ce qui est là
dessus bise neige là c'est quoi ça après
ce périple 11 minutes mais toi tu t'es
un ceux qui au nom il ya un code
olala aux canines ou moi je trouve rien
la meilleure d'autres 4,3 n'attend guère
sénat et ça va finir à vous ah ah ah ok
un test ici et loïc moi je suis quasi à
la fin quoi asie ne dit pas moi aussi je
le suis beaucoup trop pro tu te fais tu
as vu quand tu travailles tu t'es
vraiment le maquis regarde comme un
genre
de fait et aulas d'accord mais pour aux
accords rompus concernant sa moitié de
la chatte là où suis-je un coffre fort
tu l'as trouvé le franc fort bien coffre
fort ouais ouais il y en a du coffre
fort et bah oui ça joue vraiment que ça
c'est quoi ça au nom là il n'y a rien
d'intéressant
enfin c'est lorsque faire un petit
basket quoi mais moi j'en suis à 4 truc
ou faut mettre des codes mais j'ai pas
un code à la petite photo de toi plus
jeunes et un de tes amis proches
c'est incroyable alors ça là d'accord
mais alors ok on peut hein
à moi je dirais à vue mais je trouve un
truc de ouf là parce que na 4 qu'est-ce
qui me saoule
non mais c'est pour faire genre je
trouve des trucs là l'aura donc je vais
tester ça je pense que en saxe
ah ouais comme un sale et 1,4
car c'est là où ça ça ferait 15,4 24
naya rien d'accord 15-15 kata se
souvenir
mais avec quoi elle soit un cop 15 14 15
04 14 buts inscrits sur ce label ne me
dis pas ça l'a 15 04 c'est pas la même
cote sur les gens ah oui c'est vrai non
mais attends je vois rien là bas non
plus j'ai oublié ce que c'était moi
aussi j'ai trouvé un code 15-0 quelque
chose à la fin de trois novilleros
quelque chose à la fin 3 0
[Musique]
quelque chose 27 trop loin
j'étais en fait un au même endroit -
quoi et ça marche pas il faut surtout
pas faire ça c'est pas ça 09 04 09 57 03
arrête tu me stresse à ou l'or par
contre l'aja un poème de contrôle des
familles illégales à voir leur camp
détruit les documents non ça se fait pas
là il faut des lunettes ça du coup
[ __ ] ok qu'est ce qu'il ya là dedans
je peux pas aller l'autre côté en fait à
six à huit hockey
oui yes alalalala je suis paris ah là là
on détruit passan gars ont détruit tous
qu'en mer [ __ ] c'était pas ça le coach
qui complètent montville cole fait chier
mais c'est toi tu parles trop adam
normal qu'il ya un truc moi c'était
complètement mirauds c'était à caen 6
points et se termine par trou et louis
ça va vous quoi ça va être fait au
niveau 3 là j'ai déjà fini deux buts un
seul mot bien j'ai bien tranquille 09
quelque chose
03/09 quelque chose les autres ok il est
un peu plus choquants mais logiques
chose 03 09 quelque chose 0,3 à temps
mais il y avait un truc lâm 9 27 jours à
7 09 27 30 c'est parce que j'avais vu
tout à l'heure
zizou al batha au est a u les six ans
toi dany décision ah non je peux tu peux
faire de l'origami est tous avec jacuzzi
me stresse là ça qu'il faut pour la
alors tiens si j'ouvrais la petite boîte
en carton et un ciseau mais il ya des
trucs très intéressant deux ans que je
comprends pas tu m'as mis tous ses
points de 6,99
mais ça marche pas aussi moi je suis
trompé quelque part on détruit des
documents ce doux sont dans mes oreilles
ça commençait à travers ces soirs là
l'un des silos à blanc attend cet esprit
j'ai vu des images ivoirien n'a pas là
la jugent beaucoup trop près
mais [ __ ] mais qu il est si violent
que ça médias à aa et sa note correcte
peas notre camp et 6 est allé trouver
des documents
est-ce que je peux recul et s'il vous
plaît que celui là dessus ça d'accord je
prends ça aussi une carte de crédit
d'accor et ça ça dès ce moment là vous
êtes sûr que je suis désolé j'ai pas
vraiment en retard à langer ça serait ce
que six minutes et culture dès que l'on
retrouve c'est un col parce
qu'apparemment je pense que ça doit être
ça le code y'a que ça
est ce que c'est ça peut le détruire ah
non ça il faut le d301 essais se termine
par 3g actuels de fer et l'eau y est tu
trouves une carte de crédit faut bien la
détruire
ok 0 ne sais pas si je dis quelque chose
là ça détruit pas ça ah oui mais alors
attendons mais je comprends bien mais ça
et il y avait regardé les amis regardez
les amis du rhône a donné rendez vous à
la caméra il ya ça là il ya çà et du
coup je dis parce que c'est par rapport
à loïc parce que neuf il ya ça ici quand
même ok mais comment je suis pro choisi
près donc si je viens st je ne sais pas
je tente des trucs un dégât ok oiseuses
d'accord [ __ ] d'un à quatre noms comme
ça qu'est combien de temps il reste cinq
minutes ça va ça va c'est 1 0 quelque
chose de notre avis sur l'a8 lui ce
serait un 2 1 pourquoi je suis mauvais
quelle souvient jamais les chier fera
ensuite ce sera un 5-0 quelque chose 82
cents à 82 5 3 85-3 temps je vais aller
me coller contre le mur parce que
j'adore faire ça
9 27 02 09 27 0 c'est bien ça c'est pas
ça pour ça
ah mais ça va faire comme dans l'autre
il manque un a ou un b
je le faire au vif rapide à 0,7
bon déjà c'est pas ça bon je retourne à
la table à j'ai dit jeudi un indice à
non là il ya des trucs d'accord qu'un
j'ai pas compris ces défis et l'a6
on est sérieux allez on n'y arrive pas
du tout grand mais on peut rien voir là
sans déconner al baytar tu es bien dit
je suis sûr que j'ai bon mais je vois
rien j'avais prince a ok ou quoi non
mais je vois pas d'un bsa à thomas c'est
déjà ça tu n'y as et ça c'est quoi ça ok
c'est bien mais [ __ ] si je me paie je
suis trop con ça marche beaucoup mieux
comme ça d'accord l'anc est donc en
premier savaria bonjour c'est quoi ce
serait prêt à aller là d'accord donc sa
mère j'avais trop c'est le total à 1 2 3
1 2 3 à dakhla donc du coup le zéro au
chaud car entre assurance parce que
c'est à 0 ensuite tu es où toi donc
c'est 1,5 sache maintenant c'est un 3 0
3 d'accord 03 s en suivait baisse 0,8
d'accor 7,03 il dit ok borloo un mètre
ce que c'était que les non verts bien
0,3 j'ai trouvé ta carte de crédit tu
crois tu m'as trophée croix et les
cartes de crédit ne fallait pas
l'addition 0 doit bien réussi des
amendements de 3,8 à l'air c'est aussi
jeu des trois y est géré 12 détruits non
mais c'est en fait du coup j'ai trouvé
reçu lé jeudi à à blaye 2
paper toss youssef n 1 2 3 2 3 lui ou là
où la vie je le mets ça s'esquisse
matthew de trois nuits 3 2 3 8 5
roy 3 ça c'est du tout moi tour
chevalier et puis on en croit ceux qui
sont leur bleu roi la wii
trois tours chevallier pions roi les
cousins suis sorti le hic
bravo pour toi un mec je suis sorti un
butin un break en 10 minutes 30
oui je suis ici 3 loïc oui je suis sera
ben je peux finir quand même ou pas
wen avait joué telle information l'oeil
adacore bas merci bah du coup maintenant
je vais ce que je faisais ah oui 1 3
c'est ça un week end je suis sorti
quatre que ce soit 4
je sais pas si la formation est clair
pour tout le monde je suis donc sorti en
minutes 31 3 4 sa 1 3 4 1 3 4 ou 4 mois
je suis sortent pas tu es sorti voilà
d'accord va super d où ben je sais pas
encore je suis sorti en signant ses
sorties ben t'as résolu l'énigme des
pièces d'échecs et zuma mais ça c'était
isis ben bon bah voilà donc jamais
combien de temps 11 27 [ __ ] ça bon ça
va il me dit tu me talonnait frère un tu
me talonnait félicitations à méditation
abrogation un bon gagnant et cette série
quand même c'est bien ça gérer
je ne sais pas jouer non pas joyeux lui
ce genre de ce qui s'est passé
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo ça
vous a plu
bah moi ça m'a plu mais j'aimerais à
chelsea ou les deux qui n'a pas regardé
encore la vidéo ah oui ah bah non je ne
sais pas ça chez moi ça va à présent
débloqué pour quoi bon en fait quand je
m'étais trompé dans le code de la de la
valise j'avais mal rasé les chiffres et
du coup ça sauverait pas je me dis c'est
forcément autre chose ou alors j'ai
entré un mauvais code peut-être celle de
mardi comme un mois j'ai perdu 8 en
pièces d'échecs parce que c'est j'ai vu
le truc j'ai vu les quatre pièces
blanches et de machinés tout et puis ça
voudrait pas et du coup après je vous
regarde le voit ce type mais toujours de
haut si j'ai oublié qu'on pouvait se
blesser mais comment je vois lequel pied
c'est quelle pièce sans déconner quoi
tient et après j'ai fait ça ça va
c'était pression sociale de dresser les
couples non plus on n'y va plus on est
maire moi j'ai hâte de faire le
troisième étoile ben moi aussi
ben si vous aussi vous mettez un petit
live vous pouvez laisser un petit
commentaire pour dire comment vous
auriez été meilleurs que nous et mais
reconnu je patiente soit possible exact
moi j'ai centre cette vidéo n'était pas
ce qu'on ne saurait parler oculiste qui
n'ont pas ces deux casques donc voilà
c'est pas cool nous on vous aime bien
alors si vous nous aimez vous pouvez
vous abonner ici regardez ici la vidéo
de la semaine dernière ici la vidéo du
million vous aviez mais ce concept la
semaine prochaine et un concept
similaire car elle sur la chaîne je n'en
dis pas plus à très bientôt ciao